einen schönen guten tag und wieder sind
wir heute live und es geht nach wie vor
um die kanzlerkandidatenfrage der union
allerdings ist die inzwischen ja
entschieden denn armin laschet wird es
machen also der tag der entscheidung in
der union aber wir sind sozusagen noch
bei der nachlese mit knapp 80 prozent
hat sich gestern abend der
parteivorstand hinter armin laschet
versammelt markus söder sein
unionsinterner rivale hat ihm bereits
gratuliert und volle unterstützung auch
zugesagt ja und jetzt warten wir
natürlich darauf wie die reaktion von
armin laschet ausfällt nachdem jetzt
klar ist dass er die union in die
bundestagswahl als spitzenkandidat
führen wird als kanzlerkandidat
wir sprechen darüber mit nicole diekmann
gucken aber vielleicht erst noch mal
ganz kurz nach berlin und sehen dass
dort auf der pressekonferenz die in
wenigen minuten anfangen soll noch
nichts zu sehen ist aber wir gehen
natürlich wissen dass sofort rüber wenn
es dann losgeht sprechen die gesagt
vorher noch mit der kolleginnen aus dem
hauptstadtstudio mit unserer
korrespondentin nicole diekmann also
nicole wie viele steine werten armin
laschet da vom herzen gepurzelt seien
zum einen gestern abend als sich der
vorstand hinter ihm versammelt hat aber
auch zum anderen heute mittag vormittag
pardon
als dann auch markus söder seine
reaktion so gestaltet wie er sie
gestaltet hat nämlich ihm unterstützt
wer sicher einige also wir haben das ja
gestern auch schon in der
pressekonferenz die markus söder gegeben
hat gemerkt wie groß das misstrauen auch
der anwesenden journalistinnen war als
er sagte er werde sich dem abends zu
erwartenden votum des bundesvorstands
der cdu beugen da kamen mehrere
nachfragen was das genau bedeutet ob er
sich den wirklichen beugen würde dieses
misstrauen wird am ende stellt
aufgeteilt haben und sicherlich auch
gestern abend nachdem es war zu seinen
gunsten ausgefallen ambanis bombigen
ergebnis aus dem vorstand seiner eigenen
partei sicherlich noch sagen wir mal
neutral gespannt abgewartet haben was da
heute aus münchen kommt aber das war ja
sehr eindeutig erster satz
pressekonferenz markus söder die würfel
sind gefallen zweiter satz
pressekonferenz
markus söder abi laschet ist der
kanzlerkandidat der union genau die
combo vor die jetzt die ganze
pressekonferenz wieder gibst wir haben
auch noch mal den blick auf eben diese
mit markus söder denn das ist ja
natürlich interessant hören wir uns
gerade noch mal an was er gesagt hat zu
dem votum eben cdu parteivorstand
für mich ist aber klar es gibt
verantwortung für das land das wäre die
bereitschaft gewesen zu kandidieren
aber es gibt auch verantwortung für die
union nur eine geschlossene union kann
am ende erfolgreich sein
wir wollen keine spaltung wir wollen
eine geschlossene gemeinschaft ich habe
ihn angerufen und habe ihm gratuliert
habe ihm auch gesagt dass wir jetzt das
csu akzeptieren wir haben auch die volle
unterstützung angeboten als csu in
diesen wie ich glaube außerordentlich
schwierig im wahlkampf den es geben wird
und wir werden ihn ohne groll mit voller
kraft unterstützen das kann ich für mich
ganz persönlich aber ich glaube auch für
uns der csu sagen das werden wir tun
jetzt kommt es darauf an
zusammenzustehen und zusammen zu rücken
es wird sicher noch diskussionen geben
aber wir jedenfalls bei unseren beitrag
zum gemeinsamen erfolg leisten also
markus söder sichert seine
hundertprozentige unterstützung zu
darüber können wir gleich auch noch mal
sprechen wir haben aber auch schon eine
erste reaktion aus der cdu daniel
günther der ministerpräsident in
schleswig holstein galt auch als einer
von lars unterstützern
er hat sich geäußert und man muss sagen
positiv über die reaktion von markus
söder jetzt sehe ich allerdings gerade
in diesem moment kommt armin laschet ans
rednerpult deswegen geben wir direkt
darüber mit dem cdu mit
un-generalsekretär zehn jahre zuerst
spricht herzberg und dann verlasse dann
wird es fragen die möglichkeit für
fragen geben herzberg bitte ja vielen
dank meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren auch von meiner seite herzlich
willkommen hier im konrad adenauer haus
es ist eine entscheidende zeit für
unsere partei für cdu und csu
aber es ist vor allem eine entscheidende
zeit für unser land
und deshalb möchte ich zunächst einmal
darauf hinweisen das wichtigste thema
derzeit ist die bekämpfung der pandemie
das bestimmt unser land
und kein anderes thema ist so wichtig
und deswegen bleibt auch die bekämpfung
der pandemie der gradmesser für uns als
union
das heißt verantwortung tragen in diesen
zeiten aber auch in der zukunft und das
leitet uns als union fünf monate bis zur
bundestagswahl einer vertrauens wahl für
die zukunft deutschlands
gestern abend hat armin laschet als
kanzlerkandidat das vertrauen der cdu
deutschlands erhalten und heute das
vertrauen der csu
unser dank als cdu gilt markus söder und
auch markus blume und der gesamten csu
für fairness und für die unterstützung
das ist die stärke der gemeinsamen union
nach einer sehr langen und sehr offenen
sitzung wo alle argumente und positionen
ausgetauscht wurden hat der cdu-vorstand
eindeutig entschieden jedem wurde raum
gegeben über 60 wortmeldungen in dieser
unglaublich langen sitzung armin laschet
hat als bundesvorsitzender der cdu nicht
nur für offenheit und transparenz
gesorgt sondern er hat diese immer
wieder auf während der sitzung
eingefordert wir haben heute mitglieder
des bundesvorstandes nochmal im nachgang
berichtet dass sie sich nicht erinnern
können wann das letzte mal so lange so
intensiv so fair und vor allem so offen
diskutiert wurde
alles ist auf dem tisch gekommen alle
argumente alle erkenntnisse alle
positionen auch und vor allem natürlich
auch das meinungsbild in den
verschiedenen regionen deutschlands an
der basis in den verschiedenen anderen
gremien ist erörtert worden
aber am ende und so ist es in einer
demokratie gibt es eine entscheidung und
armin laschet hat auch nicht nur in der
sitzung gestern sondern auch in seinem
ganzen leben und auch in den jahren in
funktionen in partei und auch in
regierungsämtern bewiesen l stark
insbesondere wenn es drauf ankommt und
das haben wir gestern wieder erlebt
wir sind davon überzeugt dass diese
bundestagswahl nicht nur eine
vertrauens- wahl ist sondern vor allem
auch eine richtungswahl
es geht darum ob wir den kurs der mitte
in deutschland fortsetzen oder ob unser
land von einem linksbündnis regiert wird
das wollen wir verhindern
für diesen kurs der mitte steht armin
laschet und die gesamte union
wir sind der garant als cdu und csu dass
deutschland in der mitte bleibt meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren armin
laschet ist deshalb auch der
kanzlerkandidat einer starken union er
ist der kanzlerkandidat der
gesellschaftlichen mitte in deutschland
armin laschet hat und das wissen wir
alle in der cdu und auch in der csu
er hat die kraft und die ideen um
deutschland zu erneuern damit
deutschland auch in zukunft ein
wirtschaftlich starkes land ist armin
laschet ist ein leidenschaftlicher
europäer
das ist vielen auch gerade vielen
jüngeren besonders wichtig armin laschet
steht für zusammenhalt er kann führen
und er kann zusammenführen
armin laschet ist ein erfahrener
regierungschef
das ist auch wichtig für ein so großes
land wie deutschland und deswegen lassen
sie mich ganz persönlich aber auch im
namen der cdu sagen
auch für die union am heutigen tage für
die gesamte union armin laschet ist der
richtige kanzler für deutschland meine
damen und herren wir haben in den
letzten tagen eine sehr intensive eine
sehr transparente eine sehr offene
debatte geführt wir haben es uns nicht
leicht gemacht weil es schließlich um
etwas geht
es geht im september um eine wegweisende
entscheidung für die zukunft unseres
landes
die muss sorgsam abgewogen werden alle
argumente müssen auf den tisch aber es
kommt auch der moment der entscheidung
und der war gestern abend und wir haben
entschieden welches personelle angebot
cdu und csu
machen wir sind in der cdu der csu
dankbar für den guten fairen umgang in
einer sehr weitreichenden entscheidung
auch in einer sehr persönlichen
entscheidung und gut und vertrauensvoll
das gilt und auch das will ich am
heutigen tag betonen für das persönliche
verhältnis von markus söder und mir die
csu hat durch ihre entscheidung vom
gestrigen tag die entscheidung der cdu
ermöglicht das ist ein großer
vertrauensbeweis und markus söder hat
gesagt der bundesvorstand der cdu muss
entscheiden und in diesem bewusstsein
hat der bundesvorstand gestern ein sehr
deutliches votum getroffen und ich danke
markus söder dafür dass er der cdu und
auch mir persönlich die unterstützung
der csu und auch des parteivorsitzenden
der csu zugesagt hat als sie merkt dass
er während viele langjährige mitglieder
haben gesagt so transparent so offen
haben wir in diesem gremium vielleicht
noch nie diskutiert
ich wünsche mir dass diese kultur der
transparenz auch in sachen
entscheidungen in der zukunft die arbeit
der cdu auszeichnet denn die fragen die
vor uns liegen brauchen genau diese
transparenz brauchen das pro und contra
durch diskussion entsteht lebendigkeit
in der demokratie entsteht moderne
demokratie im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert alle positionen wurden
gehört und ausgetauscht und der
bundesvorstand ist ja das gremium wo
auch alle vertreten sind
alle landesvorsitzenden alle
vereinigungen die für die cdu
traditionell sehr wichtig sind der
sozialflügel und der wirtschaftsflügel
die jungen und die alten
die frauen-union die kommunalpolitiker
alle haben ihre position eingebracht und
dieser bundesvorstand vereint auch die
beiden fraktionen das votum der
cdu-fraktion cdu csu fraktion im
deutschen bundestag ist wichtig das
votum unserer kolleginnen im
europäischen parlament ist wichtig denn
die entscheidung der bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland ist ist immer
zugleich auch eine frage auf die viele
menschen in ganz europa blicken und ich
weiß auch dass sich manche eine andere
entscheidung gewünscht hätten so ist das
in einer demokratie
bei der dann am ende unter gewichtung
aller argumente
am ende entschieden wird ich bin markus
söder dankbar dass er gestern noch
einmal die bedeutung der repräsentativen
demokratie unterstrichen hat der konsens
in einer gesellschaft die zunehmend
polarisiert ist kann nur in
gemeinschaftlichen institutionen
gelingen in den parteien und am ende
auch im parlament als dem ort in dem
diskutiert wird und am ende auch
entschieden wird
ab jetzt zählt welche partei hat die
besten konzepte für die zukunft unseres
landes wer formiert das beste team um
die herausforderungen zu bewältigen
und deshalb ist es jetzt wichtig dass
die union cdu und csu jetzt als team in
den wahlkampf gehen
die cdu gewinnt diese wahl nicht ohne
die csu und umgekehrt
cdu und csu sind schwestern ein in der
deutschen parteiengeschichte
einzigartiges phänomen cdu kandidiert in
15 ländern
die csu kandidiert in bayern und mit
diesem modell sind cdu und csu
stabilitätsanker unserer republik
geworden und immer wieder in den
unterschiedlichen phasen auch
modernisierungs motor unseres landes und
gemeinsam werden wir dieses land in die
zukunft führen und markus söder wird
eine zentrale rolle dabei spielen für
die zukunft der bundesrepublik
deutschland ich werde mich weiterhin
täglich zwei täglich wöchentlich wann
immer es nötig ist mit ihm abstimmen und
diese abstimmungen sind trotz eines
wettbewerbs und unterschiedliche akzente
in den letzten tagen immer von dem
willen getragen am ende zu einem
gemeinsamen ergebnis zu kommen und ich
freue mich darauf dass bei den
entscheidungen die anstehen wie auch
dieses gemeinsam schaffen was wir in der
pandemie gelernt haben sind neue formate
diskussionen unmittelbar mit den
kreisverbänden mit unseren mitgliedern
und wir werden dieses stärken
ich will den dialog ich will die
innovativen formaten
denn durch jede dieser diskussionen
erfährt man viel über die vielfalt in
unserem land und die arbeit vor ort als
ich in die cdu in meiner jugend
eingetreten bin habe ich das nie mit der
vorstellung gemacht einmal bundeskanzler
zu werden
meine motivation war damals voller
idealismus einen beitrag zu leisten zu
einer besseren welt und das leben von
menschen konkret zu verbessern was immer
in der kommunalpolitik beginnt für mich
war aber auch wichtig dass politik nie
nur reden ist sondern auch zuhören
menschen zu hören die durch ihre eigene
schilderung ihres eigenen lebens zu
politischen entscheidungen
einen beitrag leisten zu hören
entscheiden handeln
das waren für mich drei leitplanken die
mich bis zum heutigen tag prägen und
policy mir hat das erwähnt bei allem was
wir über die zukunft denken kommt es
jetzt darauf an die pandemie zu
bekämpfen das ist das wichtigste leben
zu retten
in diesen letzten wochen und monaten bis
wir es geschafft haben dass ein großteil
der menschen in unserem land geimpft
sind
und deshalb steht das auch im
mittelpunkt der beratungen der der
bundestagsfraktion und des deutschen
bundestages und des bundesrates in
dieser woche aber von politik erwartet
man auch über den tag hinaus zu denken
wir werden nach der pandemie soziale
wirtschaftliche kulturelle folgen zu
bewältigen haben
wir haben große haushalterische
herausforderungen nach der pandemie wir
ländern derzeit viele herausforderungen
durch die aufnahme von schulden aber
nachhaltigkeit heißt die nach der krise
auch im interesse künftiger generationen
wieder zurückzuzahlen
und es darf kein weiter so geben wir
müssen als land besser schneller
moderner werden
dieser modernisierungsschub ist jetzt
nötig er war ohnehin nötig aber er ist
nach der pandemie noch nötiger mehr
innovation mehr vertrauen weniger
bürokratie nicht die vorstellung mit
vorschriften und verordnungen kriegt man
bis ins letzte jedes lebens detail
gelöst den menschen etwas zutrauen das
ist der grundgedanke der unionspolitik
auszeichnet wir müssen vielfalt als
chance sehen und nicht
als bedrohung und wir brauchen das neue
aufstiegsversprechen gerade kinder haben
gelitten unter dieser pandemie weil die
sozialen kontakte häufig weggefallen
sind
jedes kind soll aber unabhängig von der
herkunft seiner eltern den aufstieg
schaffen können in unserem land und da
wird die aufgabe nach der pandemie noch
größer sein als sie ohnehin schon ist
und wir wissen wir werden als
deutschland nicht stark wenn europa
nicht stark ist und deshalb auch unsere
nachbarn werden nach der pandemie vor
großen herausforderungen stehen und die
werden wir nur gemeinsam europäisch
beantworten können dass deutschland das
ich mir vorstelle wirkt mit an einem
bündnis von demokratien in der welt
gemeinsam mit unseren transatlantischen
partnern mit dem festen glauben an
multilaterale lösungen und unser beitrag
als europa muss offensiver werden in
einer welt auch autoritärer
gesellschaftsmodelle wir müssen für
unsere werte von freiheit von
solidarität von gerechtigkeit von
menschenwürde kämpfen in dieser welt das
muss europa wieder ausstrahlen dass es
einen wie jean monnet gesagt hat beitrag
leisten will für eine bessere welt und
unser land führt in der welt nicht durch
größe und einschüchterung sondern durch
exzellenz durch vorbild und durch
menschlichkeit dass deutschland das ich
mir vorstelle ist ein modernes land das
zusammenhält ein land in dem jeder
seinen persönlichen lebensentwurf leben
und danach streben kann seine wünsche zu
erfüllen
es ist in deutschland der vielfalt der
diversität und dieses zusammenleben wird
aber nur gelingen wenn wir eine
gemeinsame basis haben die werte unseres
grundgesetzes gelten rechthaberei
aggression polarisierung schaden dem
zusammenhalt in unserem land und gerade
wenn wir modernisieren wollen ist
vertrauen eine wichtige währung und das
ist mein ziel
so arbeite ich seitdem ich politisch
tätig bin menschen zusammenführen mit
klaren ideen am ende auch entscheiden
und für uns als cdu und csu bedeutet das
dass wir die wir in vielen jahren
unserer republik in kritischen
situationen führungsverantwortung
wahrgenommen haben dass wir auch nach
dieser pandemie unseren beitrag leisten
wollen für eine gute zukunft und für ein
modernes deutschland dann die erste
frage von herrn blank von dpa nach
vorheriger von zdf dafür sie haben ja
angekündigt dass sie sehr intensiv mit
herrn söder in den wahlkampf ziehen
werden wird das jetzt ein team der
herzen werden sozusagen nachdem herr
blume in münchen gesagt habe der
kandidat der herzen ist es jetzt noch
nicht geworden
wie sieht das dann konkret aus und heute
sieht das ziel herzen ja noch nicht so
sehr eng zusammen auswahl beide kandidat
die kandidatur woanders vorstellen
wann werden sie den ersten termin
gemeinsam haben und gemeinsam sozusagen
die kandidatur dann präsentieren also
das werden wir noch genau überlegen wie
wir das machen wir sind beide
ministerpräsidenten die auch in
regierungsverantwortung sind beide
kabinette tagen beispielsweise am
heutigen tag und wir werden in diesen
wahlkampf als cdu/csu
einsam ziehen voller grund vertrauen
zueinander und vor allem mit einem
gemeinsamen wahlprogramm das ist das
besondere dass es uns gelingen wird dass
cdu und csu mit den gleichen
modernisierungs ideen vor die
bürgerinnen und bürger bei der wahl
treten dann torjäger bitte herr laschet
die haben von transparenz gesprochen die
nacht von sonntag auf montag liegt noch
ein bisschen im dunkeln was ist denn das
argument mit dem sie markus söder
letztendlich wieder nach bayern
geschickt haben dass er sich anders
entschieden hat und fühlen sie sich
angela merkel hat sich öffentlich
zurückgehalten
von der bundeskanzlerin in dem prozess
ausreichend unterstützt also wir haben
ja durch unsere gestrige sitzung
ungewollt zu einer menge transparenz
beigetragen
zu ihrer freude und zu unserem unserer
nachdenklichkeit über unsere arbeit
ich glaube dass es auch auf dauer
gremien und sitzungen geben muss in
denen man auch vertraulich sprechen kann
und insofern glaube ich haben wir jetzt
keinen nachholbedarf an transparenz das
ist zum ersten teil ihrer frage zum
zweiten die bundeskanzlerin hat immer
deutlich gemacht dass sie in dieser
frage neutral bleiben will sich
zurückhalten will nicht bestimmen will
wer ihr nachfolger wird
ich halte das für eine sehr respektable
haltung
es beginnt mit dem ende der amtszeit von
angela merkel eine neue zeit und die zu
gestalten den weg zu finden wie wir uns
inhaltlich und personell aufstellen das
ist die aufgabe der generation jetzt
nachfolgt und deshalb wenn es kein
weiter so gibt was meine feste
grundüberzeugung ist dann ist es auch
richtig dass eine kanzlerin die 16 jahre
lang dieses land erfolgreich durch viele
krisen geführt hat
nicht selbst daran mitwirkt was denn
danach folgt der rinke bitte lasst sich
jeder ganz gerne an die eine frage
nochmal angeknüpft gab es eine art preis
den sie an söder bezahlt haben dafür
dass er nun auf die kanzlerkandidatur
verzichtet und die zweite frage ist es
hat jetzt viele spekulationen und
vermutungen gegeben dass sie beide
beschädigt aus diesem wettkampf
hervorgehen weil ne menge bemerkungen
fielen über kritische schwächen bei dem
einen mangelnde fähigkeiten zu
mobilisieren bei dem anderen wie groß
sind die schäden die dieser
auswahlprozess hinterlassen hat also auf
ihre beiden fragen würde ich zwei mal
mit nein antworten
ok dann die nächste frage herr brücker
bitte herr laschet wagen das problem der
zuspitzung in der machtfrage war ja
nicht nur eins des selbstbewusstseins
von den sünder sondern auch eins in der
cdu weil es relevante stimmen gab bis
hin zu ihren stellvertretern die gesagt
haben bist du da vielleicht überhaupt
der richtige
wie wollen sie mit denen jetzt arbeiten
zusammen arbeiten agieren welche
argumente haben sie um ihn glaubhaft zu
machen dass man auch mit armin laschet
die umfragen wieder drehen kann was ist
das zentrale argument warum sie selbst
daran glauben dass das gelingen kann und
zweite team heißt team auch sichtbar
persönlichkeiten neuaufstellung im
wahlkampf oder heißt team wir arbeiten
alle zusammen so wie bisher auch ein
team heißt dass es menschen sind
persönlichkeiten sind die daran
mitwirken
es wird nicht nur einer sein sondern es
werden viele sein
männer und frauen übrigens worauf ich
großen wert lege dass wir die breite der
union zeigen das hat mich in meinem
politischen leben immer geprägt dass
auch vertreter des wirtschaftsflügels
und des christlich sozialen flügels in
personen sichtbar erkennbar an diesem
prozess mitwirken
das will ich auch für die bundesrepublik
deutschland so vorschlagen wenn je mehr
unterschiedliche typen ideen
vorstellungen am ende zusammen arbeiten
desto mehr gelingt auch der zusammenhalt
im land
und für meinen stellvertreter und fühle
ich mich sehr unterstützt in diesem
prozess und die die eine andere
entscheidung bevorzugt hätten
insbesondere auch bei den mitgliedern in
den kreisverbänden da gingen die
meinungen auseinander
mit denen will ich den direkten dialog
suchen wie ich das seit meiner wahl zum
bundesvorsitzenden auch schon gemacht
habe und dazu haben wir mit den neuen
formaten die wir seit einigen jahren
intensiv und technisch möglich nutzen
auch die chance überall in deutschland
mit jedem zu reden und jedem zuzuhören
der seine ideen einbringt dann eine
frage von hella wir uns zukünftig
erreicht hat von der neuen passauer neue
presse lässt sich die art der
präsentation ihrer kanzlerkandidatur in
münchen daran zweifeln dass sie die
volle unterstützung der csu im wahlkampf
haben werden nein das war sehr klare
worte für die ich markus söder auch
danke und ich glaube alle wollen den
erfolg der union und alle wissen was auf
dem spiel steht ist eine
richtungsentscheidung für deutschland
über die wir hier reden wenn ein
rot-rot-grünes bündnis zusammen kommen
würde ist das eine andere republik und
das weiß jeder in bayern und das weiß
jeder in den 15 deutschen
landesverbänden der cdu dann die letzte
frage an frau böse bitte
und zum zweiten mal um die
kanzlerkandidatur insbesondere die
zweite auseinandersetzung ist zumindest
für beobachter so dass man sich fragt
was man hat das mit ihnen gemacht
was bedeutet das für sie hat sie das
verletzt wie zum beispiel die situation
in der bundestagsfraktion vor einer
woche und die zweite frage wenn sie
erlauben
sie selbst haben ja gesagt dass auch die
zusammenarbeit mit den beiden
unterlegenen kandidaten um den
parteivorsitz weitergehen soll wie wird
das jetzt aussehen wie hoffen sie auf
die unterstützung was erwarten sie von
friedrich merz oder dritten also ich bin
ein mensch der das offene wort geschätzt
und wenn man das schätzt muss man auch
damit leben können dass es dann
ausgesprochen wird und dass es
situationen gibt in denen man auch sehr
kritisch miteinander redet aber man muss
die welt nehmen wie sie ist und unsere
welt ist eine sehr sehr unterschiedliche
meinungen gibt und die dann auch
wahrzunehmen ihnen auch raum zu geben
aber am ende zu einer entscheidung zu
kommen
das ist auch das was deutschland nach
der wahl im september braucht und ich
habe mich gefreut dass wir einen
wettbewerb hatten in der cdu aber dass
beispielsweise friedrich merz der für
viele viele millionen menschen eine eine
persönlichkeit ist die sich schätzen
dass der gesagt hat ich unterstütze dich
das zeigt man kann auch aus wettbewerb
am ende so zusammenkommen dass er neues
team entsteht und darüber bin ich
dankbar und ich hoffe und bin sicher
dass uns das jetzt auch zwischen cdu und
csu
in gleicher weise gelingt vielen dank
für ihren besuch
danke schön wieder
ja so weit also das date man von armin
laschet dem cdu-chef und jetzt auch
offiziell unions kanzlerkandidaten
wir sprechen gleich mit nicole diekmann
und vielleicht noch ganz kurz die
wesentlichen aussagen also er hat sich
noch mal bedankt für eine offene und
intensive debatte die so intensiv und
offen gewesen sei innerhalb der cdu
wieder das selten erlebt habe bzw auch
wie anderem dass dort wohl selten erlebt
haben
er ist der csu dankbar für den fairen
umgang und den großen vertrauensbeweis
er wolle große panthers transparenz und
offenheit beibehalten auch in künftigen
inhaltlichen fragen denn das stärke eben
die lebendigkeit und demokratie
innerhalb der unionsparteien und auch
innerhalb der cdu
söder werde eine zentrale rolle spielen
auch interessant darüber kann man gleich
auch noch mal sprechen
das land insgesamt brauche einen
modernisierungsschub und wir sprechen
wie gesagt mit nicole diekmann unserer
zdf hauptstadtkorrespondent in nicole
armin laschet also jetzt er ist es ist
geblieben war war für dich sein eindruck
bzw
die hatte auf mich gewirkt belastet muss
jetzt scherben zusammenkehren und das
weiß er auch dass hat man gerade in
dieser pressekonferenz gemerkt und trotz
alledem hat man auch noch mal diese
berühmten starke nerven die im jahr
kennerinnen in den letzten tagen auch
schon immer wieder attestiert haben
bemerkt also er wirkte gelöst kann er
auch sein er ist wenn auch nicht mit
einem traumergebnis jetzt tatsächlich
zum kanzlerkandidaten der union erklärt
worden
und er hat sich gegen markus söder
durchgesetzt er nun auch nicht gerade
als jemand gilt der schnell aufgibt
beziehungsweise nicht breitbeinig
auftreten würde deswegen hat das ganze
ja auch über eine woche gedauert
stichwort scherben zusammenkehren man
hat schon gemerkt in dieser rede es war
ihm sehr wichtig immer mal wieder drauf
zu rekurrieren dass man eine union ist
dass man zusammenarbeiten muss das weiß
er auch er braucht oder an seiner seite
das ist jetzt nicht nur so dass armin
laschet huldvoll sagt markus ich finde
dich als zentral eine zentrale figur in
meinen wahlkampf ein sondern da geht es
natürlich auch darum möglichst viel
kontrolle über markus söder zu haben für
den fall dass es mit den unfall
nicht weiter nach oben geht was sie
zweimal auch gesagt hat gerade in seinem
eingangsstatement war er wird die
regionalkonferenzen die regional
beziehungsweise die landesverbände
einbinden in den nächsten monaten eher
wird in den dialogen mit dir hier mit
denjenigen die ihn nicht wollten
das war ja das narrativ der letzten tage
immer wieder die basis will söder da
mussawi laschet jetzt also hin das heißt
er muss nicht nur die eigenen leute
überzeugen nicht nur die wähler innen
überzeugen von sich sondern zum teil
eben auch die eigenen leute
er muss außerdem wie gesagt söder in
schach halten er muss das verhältnis
zwischen cdu und csu im auge behalten
und er muss außerdem versuchen das
eigene image aufzupolieren also armin
laschet hat eine ochsentour vorsicht
dass man das tags wahl im september
das will ich auch sagen er hat sie alle
hände voll zu tun du sagst er muss söder
in schach halten
wie könnte ihm das gelingen was glaubst
du wie sieht seine strategie seiner
sagte er würde sicher auch in zentraler
rolle sehen in zukunft in deutschland
was könnte er damit gemeint haben
das könnte zum beispiel bedeuten dass er
söder sollte lasse die wahl gewinnen als
minister nach berlin hohe
beziehungsweise sollte sie das nicht
wollen das ist ja die große frage ob der
sich tatsächlich entscheidet unter einem
kanzler armin laschet ein ministerium zu
übernehmen oder doch lieber in bayern zu
bleiben
wir erinnern uns bis vor wenigen tagen
sagen wir mal bis rund vor zehn tagen
war ja auch die allgemeine auffassung
syrer sei der festen überzeugung sein
platz sei in bayern bis als ich dann
doch hat also doch geäußert er dass er
doch keine ambitionen hat auf die
kanzlerschaft also entweder holte söder
ins kabinett sollte er denn das
kanzleramt gewinnern der guter armin
laschet oder aber die csu wird sich wird
sich da ein großes preisschild anheften
und wichtige ministerien für sich
beanspruchen und auf dem weg dahin wird
er wie gesagt so sehen dass er wieder
einen wichtigen platz einräumt dass er
wieder zur geltung kommen lässt im
wahlkampf er braucht ja auch die csu
sehr klar die grünen noch ein paar
stimmen aus unserer
nach sozialen netzwerken mit rein nach
rosa hellblau über youtube laschet hat
keine führungsstärke charisma geschweige
denn ein souveränes politisches standing
das ist eine katastrophe so seine
meinung klar ist steffi über facebook
auf keinen fall hat sich dieses hat sich
die cdu damit einen gefallen getan nur
dem parteivorstand zu rate zu ziehen und
sämtliche stimmen aus der bevölkerung zu
ignorieren wirkt überheblich und
verkörpert macht ich bezweifle sehr dass
diese entscheidung vertrauen schafft das
ist ja auch noch mal ein interessanter
punkt also ganz offenkundig war es ja so
dass an der basis vielerorts markus
söder klare vorteile hatte was so das
meinungsbild anbelangt aber eben nicht
im cdu parteivorstand auch wenn da eine
nicht ganz zu unterstützende minderheit
sich auch relativ deutlich für sogar
ausgesprochen hat also das ist ja ein
zentraler punkt der stadt jetzt schaffen
muss dass er eben diese zweifler an ihm
innerhalb der union in den nächsten
wochen von sich überzeugen muss ganz
genau das hat er ja eben wie ich eben
auch schon gesagt habe betont in seiner
rede das ist ihm klar
es hat ja auch die zweifel gestern
genährt nachdem markus söder in seiner
pressekonferenz gesagt hat also ich
beuge mich eine meiner entscheidung des
cdu vorstands wenn die breite mehrheit
der cdu armin laschet als
kanzlerkandidaten möchte dann wird er
das und da fing die spekulationen wieder
an was bedeutet denn eben breite
mehrheit wie definiert söder das geht es
um die parteigremien geht es eben um die
basis da hörte man eben in den
vergangenen tagen immer wieder die basis
sei er für schüler aber man muss auch
immer festhalten es gab jetzt keine
urabstimmung in der union in der auch
nicht in der cdu aber wir haben es ja
zum beispiel gesehen an der jungen union
da waren glaube ich 14 landesverbände
für söder also da hat armin laschet echt
einiges vor sich
eine frage an dich direkt von goalkeeper
über youtube warum hat die entscheidung
des vorstandes bei dieser großen
unterstützung denn so lange gedauert
es kamen so ist zu hören
armin laschet hat das ja auch relativ
süffisant gerade in einer antwort gesagt
wir konnten das ja gestern quasi in
echtzeit verfolgen weil unglaublich viel
raus gelassen wurde an einige
journalisten die quasi in echtzeit auf
twitter zitat herausgegeben haben
verhandlungs stände pegelstände
demnach wurde viel geredet man hat sich
sehr bereits ausgesprochen
man hat miteinander gesprochen das hat
da stellt heute ja auch noch mal betont
und dann das finde ich einen
interessanten punkt den man auch betonen
muss war die verfahrensfrage anscheinend
mich so richtig geklärt also
überraschender weise war man wohl
überrascht davon dass es gestern abend
zu einer abstimmung kommen könnte im
parteivorstand
dann war die technische frage weil das
ja digitale sitzung war war nicht so
richtig geklärt da war man nicht gut
vorbereitet dass hat das ganze noch mal
zusätzlich in die länge gezogen wir
haben auch ein paar positive stimmen zu
leistet das wollen wir nicht
unterschlagen ich in der nähe noch mal
zum beispiel sehr virtuell auf facebook
alleine dass er anspricht dass andere
sich wie ihn anders gewünscht haben
zeigt dass er jedenfalls dass politische
worts beherrscht und julien kleiner über
youtube schreibt kann mir mal jemand
argumente gegen laschet aufzeigen weil
ich weiß nicht was hier alle haben der
mann hat sich gegen söder gegen merz und
roetgen durchgesetzt und das ist ja nun
auch eine leistung also das muss man
ihnen ja schon zugutehalten er hat
nehmerqualitäten und offensichtlich auch
ster fähigkeiten wenn man das mal so
nennen will
das hat das ist ja genau das was ihm
wahrscheinlich auch viel zuversicht
gegeben hat in den vergangenen tagen in
diesem ringen in diesem wettkampf gegen
sünder der ja auch kein kind von
traurigkeit ist die hat er aber
also man muss nochmal sich auf der zunge
zergehen lassen dass es wirklich knapp
war für armin laschet der als
vorsitzender der ungleich größeren
schwester der beiden parteien der cdu
wirklich um ein haar auch gescheitert
wäre und jetzt auch nicht wie sich
gemütlich durch den wahlkampf also
zumindest geborgen im inneren seiner
eigenen partei schaukeln lassen kann so
ist die situation
nicht also er hat starke nerven bewiesen
aber tatsächlich war das jetzt kein
einfach eingefahrener sieg wie man ihn
eigentlich hätte vermuten können
die dia bislang gezeigt hat die wird er
auch weiterhin noch brauchen in diesem
jahr das ist sicher wir haben einen
weiteren sozusagen unterstützer von
armin laschet danken günter den
ministerpräsidenten in schleswig
holstein hat sich eigentlich immer
positiv überlastet geäußert auch von ihm
gibt es eine reaktion
ich glaube es ist gut dass jetzt eine
entscheidung da ist etwas was die
parteien auch dringend erwartet haben
was glaube ich auch viele wählerinnen
und wähler dringend erwartet haben
und natürlich freue ich mich darüber
ausdrücklich dass armin laschet
spitzenkandidat der union für die
bundestagswahl im september wird ich
will aber vorab sehr deutlich auch sagen
großen respekt für markus söder
nicht nur dass er seine bereitschaft zur
kandidatur erklärt hat sondern auch die
art wie er jetzt gerade in den letzten
tagen auch dazu beigetragen hat dass wir
eine gemeinsame lösung gefunden haben er
hat gestern das fenster auch dafür
geöffnet dass es diese lösung gibt indem
er klar gesagt hat das hat das votum des
cdu bundesvorstandes auch akzeptieren
wird das votum war eindeutig gestern für
armin laschet und von daher hat er heute
auch gerade eben in seinem presse
statement sehr deutlich gemacht dass er
diese kandidatur auch unterstützt also
noch mal lob für markus söder jetzt ist
es sozusagen im sieg im triumph immer
relativ einfach den unterlegenen dann zu
loben aber in der tat ist es ja so man
braucht sich nach wie vor gegenseitig
cdu und csu und das interesse und das
ziel der cdu muss es nun sein
insbesondere von armin laschet die guten
umfragewerte zu bekommen
die markus söder ja schon hat man ganz
genau und es muss auch ziel seien ins
kanzleramt zu ziehen ansonsten müsste er
sich das alles ja überhaupt nicht geben
und das geht nur gemeinsam mit der csu
nicht nur weil die csu so toll im
plakate kleben ist und so viele wähler
innen stimmen zur verfügung stellt aus
bayern sondern auch ganz einfach weil
keine partei gewählt wird die in sich
zerstritten ist
offener streit jetzt noch nach dieser
woche die wir gesehen haben das wird
jetzt natürlich alles versucht um zu
deuten
also wenn das jetzt sagt wir hatten
einen sehr offenen einen sehr
transparenten prozess na ja also es war
offener streit ist dass wir keine partei
und das kann die union gerade jetzt auf
den letzten metern es sind nur noch fünf
monate bis zur bundestagswahl nicht
wollen man muss jetzt geschlossen
auftreten
denn gerade konservative wähler innen
andere aber auch mut ihren streit nicht
also was will man von einer partei
erwarten die in sich zerstritten und
damit mit sich selber beschäftigt ist
das ist ja auch noch mal wichtig sowohl
10 jagt der den ausschlag gemacht hat
der cdu-generalsekretär als auch armin
laschet haben auf eine eigentlich
selbstverständlichkeit heute hingewiesen
dass das wichtigste thema im moment
eigentlich corona ist wir sie stecken
mitten in der dritten welle aber wenn
man sich überlegt wird sich die cdu und
die csu in den vergangenen tagen
vornehmlich beschäftigt hat dann wissen
wir es war so wie wir das mitbekommen
haben nicht die pandemie eine frage noch
von es an die sander über facebook hat
die cdu mit der wahl von armin laschet
annalena baerbock soeben zur kanzlerin
gemacht oder vielleicht etwas breiter
formuliert was bedeutet diese
personalentscheidung jetzt für die
politische konkurrenz ist das für die
grünen zum beispiel von vorteil oder
nachteil
das ist jetzt laschet und nicht so teuer
geworden ist die die frage würde ich
gerne ende september beantworten wenn
die wahl gelaufen müssen solange meiner
seite
ja genau deswegen will es ja auch gebaut
mit immer kompliziert also nein spaß
beiseite
wahrscheinlich war man auf söder er
eingestellt in sachen das wird der
härtere gegner in puncto eloquenz in
puncto hybride kriegsführung ja also
söder ist gut darin sich die themen der
anderen einzuverleiben
jeder hat den naturschutz sehr für sich
entdeckt in bayern in den vergangenen
jahren das hat man bei den grünen auch
mit stirnrunzeln gesehen das ist ein
grünes thema das will man sich natürlich
nicht wegnehmen lassen
aber wie gesagt auch die grünen sind
profis auch die wissen man sollte einen
armin laschet nicht unterschätzen weil
das nämlich schon so oft passiert ist
und er das zu seinem vorteil dann
umgemünzt hat
wir bleiben gespannt und beobachten
natürlich jetzt die weitere entwicklung
in berlin und das auch mit dir vielen
dank nicole nochmal für das gespräch und
die sehr interessanten aussagen
dankeschön und wir hören zum schluss
noch mal rein was der unions
kanzlerkandidat armin laschet gesagt hat
noch mal sein zentrales statement wir
haben in den letzten tagen eine sehr
intensive eine sehr transparente eine
sehr offene debatte geführt wir haben es
uns nicht leicht gemacht weil es
schließlich um etwas geht
aber es kommt auch der moment der
entscheidung und der war gestern abend
wir sind in der cdu der csu dankbar für
den guten fairen umgang in einer sehr
weitreichenden entscheidung auch in
einer sehr persönlichen entscheidung und
gut und vertrauensvoll
das gilt und auch das will ich am
heutigen tag betonen für das persönliche
verhältnis von markus söder und mia
die csu hat durch ihre entscheidungen
vom gestrigen tag die entscheidung der
cdu ermöglicht das ist ein großer
vertrauensbeweis und wir sind gespannt
was die union mit diesem
vertrauensbeweis jetzt anfangen wird in
den nächsten tagen und wochen soweit
also nochmal das statement von armin
laschet dem kanzlerkandidaten der union
hinter dieses thema können wir also
einen haken setzen
danke nochmal für die rege teilnahme und
wünschen euch einen schönen tag und
sagen bis demnächst